hey it's evan and i believe it's
important to thank the people who have
contributed to your business who have
contributed to your life and who have
helped you become the business owner and
the person that you are today and so
every week i make a new video thanking
somebody who's had an impact on my life
in business and today i want to thank a
dese a dese is started off as my
programmer now he's in charge of my
operations here at have a comical calm
he started with me in 2008 and we've
been through a ton of stuff and a lot of
battles and Wars together and when I
first brought a decent board I wasn't
sure if it was gonna work out I was part
of an internship program I had had
interns in my company before when you
first started up it's a it's a great way
to to launch a business and get some
help and doesn't cost you a lot of money
and I had mixed experiences some of the
interns I had were really great i've had
three interns that really helped propel
my business forward and a whole bunch of
duds and others who I had to let go
because it wasn't working out so when
the opportunity that these came along I
was a little bit jaded I had some bad
experiences with internet before I
didn't know if I want to do another one
again and then thesis situation was a
little bit different because he wasn't
even in the country he was outside the
country to get into the country he
needed to get my approval to say yeah I
want this guy so I was responsible for
him the other interns I came to me you
know if it didn't work out I could let
them go after a week a couple days even
but with him now I was responsible for
him for I forget how many months and so
it made me made me worried that whatever
didn't work out so it's okay let me let
me talk to the guy and so I got on the
phone with him we set up a skype call
and I knew was nervous you could tell
and he had a very simple website we can
kind of see his picture on it and he
wanted to become a programmer and want
to be a team lead and wanted to you know
do things with his career but he didn't
have a lot of experience he had a ton of
passion
and that's kind of what sold me on it
because I looked at it ah you know this
guy has done some work but not that much
and I do need some help but is it gonna
be worth it or not you know maybe I want
somebody who's had a little bit more
experience but he had so much passion
for what he was doing and for week what
he wanted to do that I said this is
worth it this is worth trying even
though he doesn't have the skills in
Syria that I need yet even though I'm
responsible for him and he's coming to
the country because of me it's worth it
it's worth going for because he has the
passion I'd rather hire somebody who's
super passionate what they're doing and
who's eager and hungry to learn and
jumps at any challenge than the people
who have tons of skills but don't have
that passion to be successful and so he
came and it's been great and it's worked
out and every time I have a major
problem a deist is there battling
alongside with me helping me fix it the
guy loves taking on new projects new
opportunities any time I come up with a
new idea a lot of people would say
that's crazy or they just see the amount
of war that's involved where he sees it
as an exciting opportunity a new
challenge and I always know that if I
have a problem a decent in my corner
back me up I don't micromanage him I'm
not all over him to say do this do this
do this I know he gets his stuff done
and I know that if my website went down
or if I had a major crash or some
program he would be working just as hard
as I would to fix it to get it back up
because he bleeds every chemical calm
and I love it and I love him for that so
thank you at these you've been an
awesome help to my business since 2008
and I'm looking forward to tons more
years working with you and for everybody
you know with your business think about
somebody who you can think you can make
a video you can send an email you can
write a letter you can take them out to
lunch recognize the people in your life
in your business who have had an impact
say thank you it'll make you feel better
it'll make them feel better do something
today then make it happen believe
those are watching you like this video
please give it a thumbs up below i love
seen those come in and here i want to
hear from you you have a comment about
this video or question for your company
leave it in the section below I always
read those and i'll make a video
response to you thank you guys I'll see
you soon